a wired complete interview
is pedro pascal ageless the answer is
ageless
is nathan phillian really pedro pascal i
think pedro pascal is really nathan
fillion because
he's pedro pascal
is that oberyn martel
that is oberyn
martel how delighted we are to see you
intact
it seems unlikely that you'll be coming
back to game of thrones seeing is that
you don't really have a head anymore but
um i could come back with like a tongue
and an esophagus being like that's gross
the iconic character i'm about to create
is the [ __ ] in this interview
it's colin firth channing tatum julianne
moore jeff bridges halle berry i think
it's just really brave of fox to make a
big sequel with a bunch of nobodies
thank you that's really good yeah
neither of the two of you are on the
main movie poster
what is going on there guys it's
definitely up to us
i don't want people to be upstaged by
this
much
sexiness
well okay i was i was really bad at the
lasso
okay
you're just gonna say it i was i sucked
at it so like the lasso i just had to
stand there and just be like you know
you had to do that i mean i had a rope
that like no longer continued past my
thumb
the director's going to kill me he's
going to be like right i'm going to die
i felt more confident with the whip
it i enjoyed it more
[Applause]
you guys are big deals like everyone
loves narcos you guys are big deals now
you're in kingsman you're going to tell
me i'm a big deal while i'm sitting next
to halle berry what is it narcos is
amazing this guy is infiltrating uh the
cartel
do you think you could have done that as
an outdoor no
well
how do you like working for netflix it's
terrible embarrassing it's so an
embarrassing place to work it is if i
tilt it towards your direction
then it'll kill me take this away cause
you you mean nothing to me while i have
my ipad i don't need you i need this the
playstation
nintendo
er playstation is the way that everyone
says they just made it spelled it out
different to make it kind of sound look
crazy
i mean who doesn't want to just have a
little cap of crunch and it doesn't
taste like what is this taste like a
caramel
popcorn
childhood butter a mother's loving
embrace
a german shepherd in the backyard
there's barely
any water in this mark
we're in a drought so the climate change
is real well
you're all right
um complicated action sequences which
are described to you like you know it
just turns into this kind of language
and
you know
you know
is there anything you can tell us about
this character that you're going to
absolutely i
oh oh yeah right exactly there it is
there it is
i literally like it'll go off and if i
get back warner brothers put a chip in
the back of my head roll in wonder woman
i play
what is one skill you wish you were
really good at saying so that i wouldn't
give me i am dying to be a really uh it
was it was shockingly easy we were
terrified
[Laughter]
like you've used the lasso she has a
lasso who uses a lasso better you were
wonder woman i mean
wonder woman
it's basically a 706 page book about uh
death
all the guys i know they like to read
nonfiction i like fiction i think the
truth
[Music]
is in
fiction one of the actors
she wouldn't wear her robe do you
remember yeah
so we're in the green room you know and
playing words with friends or something
with
with david and charles is reading the
paper and next to him is a completely
naked person
and she's trying to talk with him and
he's like
[Laughter]
and he looks up at me and he's like
trying to move in like tight leather
armor you know i'd like finally like
learned how to i'm like look i can make
that
noise
and then they put on this tight like
leather armor and i'm like
it's gone i can't do it anymore you know
you're one of people magazine's sexiest
man alive
in plaid and he's got the plaid to prove
it i want to dance with somebody
with somebody who loves me
okay when you do it like that just so
you know it gets creepy it's it's not
it's not sweet enough
i was in awe i was i am
[Music]
seriously everyone's been saying that
like everyone's been able to win each
other
you ever been to dollywood oh i've never
been to dollywood but i've been to
dollywood you know what i'm saying not
really
not really
i'm not always a happy junk i can tell
you that
this one just made me really sweaty i
don't know what's going on because it's
hot in here might be the room might be
but you don't look like you're hot i
mean you're hot
thank you so much
i'm gonna work with pedro pascal
that was it finally how was it that was
my lifelong dream oh three lawn orders
[Laughter]
and like basically how could i get my
screenplay made and you guys to start
send it to me i'll i'll have a look
i'm the funny one are you possibly you
think you make a lot of people laugh
yeah when i tell you guys i cried
through the footage because in a good
way don't worry um because
it's this is terrible i'm like my god
i've been waiting my whole life
for the cast down here when did you guys
realize how big of a deal this show was
going to be at what point was it when
they said star wars
heard of it would you rather get this is
the way tattooed on your face or your
back i'll take it all my back okay and
on my back might be a completely
different message as well
let's talk about sex baby let's talk
about you and me let's talk about all
the good things
let's talk about